he's done it all he's been a TV drag and
a TV shark but now business mogul Kevin
O'Leary is wading into the political
waters for the first time as a candidate
for the leadership of the Conservative
Party and he joins me now in our studio
also for the first time great to be here
thank you why don't I think a lot of
people know of you is the persona that
they see on TV what do you see here I
see a lot of money wasted
life's hard money doesn't care you've
got to differentiate between making
television and making policy so the guy
we see on that show necessarily it's not
the guy we would see not a hoodie be and
you're making television you want to be
controversial you want to explore ideas
and unique ways you want to be emotional
in ways that make good TV we're going to
have a long drawn-out election cycle for
the next two years in the battle for
taking back Ottawa you know I don't
consider 2019 an election this is going
to be an exorcism some of the things
that you're saying are reminiscent of
President Donald Trump I'm half Lebanese
half Irish if there was a wall in Canada
I wouldn't be here we're a very
inclusive society I would never change
that president Trump is a unique
president because he is not going by
protocol Arlene Dickinson one of your
co-workers on one of the shows with very
Oh spoken about how she felt about you
running this should take a quick look at
the clencher one of the first questions
I ever get asked when we talk about the
show is whether Kevin is the same person
off the show as he is on the show the
answer that question is yes and that
should put enough fear into Canadians I
have noticed with you it hurt me we've
been friends for such a long time with
politics break a friendship that's bad
that's a tough thing to the personal
side yeah what did your family say when
I went to vote in the last election
I voted for Harper I'm a conservative
and as you slide my study went together
and I said to him now when you get in
there you're going to vote work and
serve the family and he looked at me
said I don't think so
I'm gonna vote for why I want to go for
I said you must be kidding you're not
going to vote for Trudeau he wouldn't
tell me but I know what he was telling
me this next election I have to make
sure my daughter and son
vote for me what is your wife saying she
said to me this is not what I would
choose for us but if you want to do it
as I've done for you for all of these
years I'll Becky that's all I need to
hear wow that's a good partner